all right try it again three two one
three ha I can't tell if it worry
whatever are all right here we go
all right ready three two one hello
everybody look how or not I think oh oh
we we did bid the clap okay you count
down oh hey do you are so dumb I was
trying to provide us an owl alright
hello everybody and welcome to drunk my
craft with our special guest yamimash
hello everyone i'm ash Ketcham oh yeah
oh yes how much potato ice oh um we're
here back into left for dead land with
um who are you who are you again Bob
odden Lauri
wait who are you I'm just me but wait
wait the guy is gonna die in this
episode okay all right
yummy who do you want to be oh I'll be
the cool old guy with a shotgun hurt oh
yeah right oh I guess that makes you a
nice Shane and Rick okay
oh god it's one Shane hey no we're gonna
mix it up I know we're still doing the
entry room hey I want to be the whole
bunk yo wasn't this the nuclear test
town that we found where [ __ ] blew up
really hardcore last time what remember
at the end of the last Walking Dead
episode we were in like a biggest
explosion no I don't remember that at
all that happened it's been a while
since we did drunk minecraft because
it's hard to been good schedule but
since we got our special guest here we
decide that we're going to be so getting
the character everybody here we go oh
they're sure not Hershel that's right
okay so I think we're losing Yami guys
why huh oh my mashed potatoes ah well on
this video makes that funny was lorry
Yami's it is like really bad England
land Internet oh I found a hole Oh Jerry
haha dee dee of Ethiopian Internet Yami
yeah my internet is terrible ah he got
it's so sad I thought I always thought
that your English internet was good yeah
here's like eight megabits down ah
that's good that's happy to help I mean
your bathroom is on the Walker that's
right by Mark is ah yummy kill it with
fire or a sword shovels are good against
Hitler zombies anything you guys so it
was you helping raids they don't have a
head mark I honestly don't know where
you are or building right next to you
dicks oh hey there you are
you [ __ ] oh you're a de facto a
ankles I'm glad you made it okay Shane
Rick all right we need to go find a less
shitty part of town and get some loot
cuz I need a sword
okay um check these buildings we gotta
survive and they're not some a bit
railing lockers over here oh I'm real
worried Hey look at this awesome armor
hey zombie what bet how do you get down
with armor it's [ __ ] are clearly
sore dick oh I have armor I should put
that on huh huh guys what guys what what
where how are you we got a protection oh
there's awesome sanur see very well so I
got a Meister get the sobbing you get
shame I need y'all you gotta do the
Hershel correctly obvious liked it oh
man oh man oh man oh I know
closed closed yummy come on and chest
you gotta go a role in the best in the
buildings but these are all shitty
buildings that are gonna have anything
inside oh yeah well let me just walk in
this shitty building and Joe Etherington
oh yeah so um be okay listen this
Sharada is officially broken I'm the
wrong
oh yeah there's a big hole there Wade oh
my die from us going gun I have one
arrow is that good
ah maybe nice
I have hungry duel I'm on the rooftop I
think if you hit someone with it like if
you punch someone with an arrow it
should do damage did somebody give it
out where there are sticks over here man
oh you want to see my name tag ah I
found it just go ahead
did you put it out haha you do SH
adductors it's over here hey kids
see hey hey come in Hey hi guys come on
arrows me go to the top of your head you
listen here I'm sticking out of the top
mark yours is straight out of the top
here and there's an arrow coming
straight out of your left hand see it oh
I see the one in my left hand the wall
your head disappeared you put it on your
egalitarian herschel where's barb again
oh there is my er say get so far away
no no Hershel don't blame me be brave I
got your loving I mean I got you Yami
I'm hoping I'm out there you go I've
dated here what that did your damn
Internet let's make it good day I'll
tell you I'm having you live in you yeah
I found some zombies we're gonna hide
mysteriously oh no what'd you do Fred
Rick oh my god what the hell just
happened
oh I thought you were a zombie I went
inside for two seconds
hello Laurie mommy where D or E I did
this for a that's sprouting gum what
you're drowning gonna kill me if I let
you come close to me
no no killing Oh turn on Bruno mode I
have redstone aquellas Neil never did
like you shame I never liked you and I
have a lawyer shame you did the Laurie
for this for her Oh Laurie
uh Yami do you want a worry that's
pretty close is that your lorry
oh hey got uh oh it's not getting dark I
have no sword could people kill me
people unnamed we need food in a shelter
you can have the stone what I love the
iron one dibs mercial you're running
right at missile triangle sorry
no mine good yes I have a fist it didn't
hurt that bad you have armor and I have
a fish she's a doll is it wonderful
two hearts up and I'm starving - yes
Ami's was my slug words up I took my
cobble with my door okay so anyway your
Tovar never mentioned this but I'm
drinking captains and dr. pepper
what are you all drinking I'm drinking
jingling frickin a very manly a hard
apple cider ah yummy vodka straight just
up good yeah huh Yami's kickin it up
about here that's pretty hardcore I've
punched this on me 20 times
uses floor you want some help is it my
old
you got in my way i'ma show you what
right in front of me wow you're murdered
people left and right Rick I
accidentally can't stand for this wait
till I eat and replenish my hell Rick
array with my sward she couldn't handle
it good huh huh ha ha ha ha ha are you
need puff it up and get used to that
kind of thing if we're gonna have any
fun no I didn't hear you use this to
kill me I eat the sword but here take
this off here I don't you literally
walked right in front of me well hide
you show you walk right in front of it I
change with nothing I could do
Oh a zombie huh alright so we done kill
each other we done no we don't kill each
other
we do I guess yeah so are we old friends
now I've got scopes legian in here if
you guys are family or friends though
okay I've got rotting flesh oh okay
where'd you get steak zombie never
cleared my inventory I still got this
okay alright so anyway we need to
survive which we've already failed yeah
object I haven't died yet well just a
regular way my again
alright Hershel Laurie you're okay I
could be a major - Laurie finish your
cue it up
okay so anyway were Shiell or shut up
wait for show ha ha ha
kara I'm the leader of our group so
Tommy oh my god zombies are falling off
of the buildings around us should be
following Shane I'm the only appropriate
leader for this group Rick hey I found a
chest ape it always was good fresh rain
howdy pard evil rain is a celebrity from
self oh I got all iron stuff are you
dick there's a chest on the street I'm
thinking not the hardest thing to find
zombies love being overrun Baja same
I mean shangri-la don't you guys spread
out you guys are the worst at surviving
a zombie apocalypse where are you Bob
are you joining us 20 was on his own you
summer is a meal no that's not iron its
irony it's kind of it's not a it's a
made of iron thought but it it seemed a
DIY crap actually it's made of sharp
teeth that's how you made you up the
game wait wait no yeah I was meted wage
was exactly how I planned it username or
password oh no yeah alright no I know I
have Lori and Hershel all the myself and
I are you gonna do with them did you
turn into a pirate yummy yeah yeah he
does or don't you guys go I don't know
I'm all alone running in circles I'm
over here with Yami winning oh there are
a bunch of zombies though I'm going in
to bill
trying to find stuff I don't know where
you guys are but I don't care it's too
many walkers what others are no job
watch Oh
Oh what wait oh what a show whoa whoa
all right let's judge Oh yummy huh you
know those things from Star Wars to
traitor thingies what are those called
yeah the job done I did your job job
yeah yeah oh did you they're called
jealous
jump jump you know ah job jobs yah me
knows I'm dying about don't don't don't
encourage Marquis tell I'm here with
mocking yeah yeah see unchanged payroll
famous youtubers here yeah we know what
we're on about PO I'm going upstairs
Yami you trucks later I know like I
don't know that guy that nobody like the
people with more than 2000 subscribers
but I like the way you said it by karma
too hard oh I just realized I wasn't
recording my audio so [ __ ] off oh god
damn it
no I think you are recording had my
register with a webcam recording my
audio so it sounds like ass oh my audio
in the beginning will sound like ass and
then halfway through it's just gonna be
like Oh suddenly after I die but I can
see it's a miracle
alright well let's go back to talking
smack mark the professional who knows
how to record through his webcam hey I
found iron stuff after i respawned
apparently I'm a trapdoor with lava at
the bottom you want to see what's down
there Yami yeah let me jump down uh okay
I'm coming down I was a little it's like
climactic but I'll take it
it's just lava oh [ __ ] Gettier hey hey
Rick I found it all iron armor you like
how defenseless there got a redstone
torch you don't want to mess with me she
I'm done I'm done I'm done
are you [ __ ] killing each other he
got let guy bonds big bike groans right
cry bonds hospital robbed or Gonski
borgen's
gonna let rygaard's beat a breeze
ricochet knee where Rick we gotta work
yeah thank you and I should just get
away from these guys they're the worst
yeah I don't like how they'd be right
let's go pirate Herschel's gone rock I
hear more from pirate Hershel I like
that
tell us a story of your seafaring ways
are backing 1956 as I was sailing to
seven really super they're pirates and
white whale are oh look it's them hey
hey pirate Herschel Hey oh man take
their loot I'm not a very good leader
Yami hear what I mean pirate Herschel
here you need to protect yourself or
order a purple pass this is a walker oh
yeah um wait what purple pants what oh
yeah purple pants pants oh well good for
you and stuff all right on nest hill
moving on as leader I say we move on
Ford's doors don't like how you're
running thing Shane I should be the
leader
okay pirate awesome Heather go Yannick
okay I follow you and we got cast out
but I've been the leader of this
question so I came out of the hospital
for no good reason huh okay all right
well set a reference to the show they
should go watch no I don't know why but
I'm extremely bored let's move on here
yes way okay come on pirate her social
way for five miles
okay pilot my right my oh Sh
I don't think we've ever done anything
for five miles on this though either
except maybe ride the cart Stewart
minecarts to our death in the last way
we're those quite a bit one time we made
a 5-mile explosion on a live stream yeah
that's pretty funny that's fun who was
waiting for that
wait wasn't there for that walkers
they're raining from the skies your
accents are terrible
wait just saying me I'm not saying minor
any better your accents are bad and you
should feel bad that you think I feel
bad cuz I might yeah oh my god it's an
Enderman me ask you something that's
that's not my line right there are there
Enderman in the walking dead I didn't I
didn't think that was a care here before
that's season four yeah will her alert
everybody it's following us uh I see
those ahead the lights are working up
down there did yarn head
there's probably looting is terrible
there's what Lou you sure my thing was
terrible I said Laurie she's likely
they're following us Oh Oh what hello
giant spiders just a computer five I'm
shook flipped you think you're lost cuz
you're leading the I'm going in this
building screw you I don't care about
you hey what's building this one that
I'm going in well I I don't stop I'll
see you you don't see my name tag no
especially nice I like it and stuff I'm
going in this building cuz I like the
way it looks I like the wave I like to
well I like to take it's sterile and I
like the taste it's are you gonna stick
it out here I'm going to go all the way
down here and explore the area okay my
rehearsal and we never saw Herschel
again hi I have three iron swords does
anyone need a better weapon I need a big
axe cuz I'm trying to break stone bricks
with my sword I found kur all that was
the stairs I was breaking never mind I'm
an idiot
haha Oh diamond oh oh oh oh diamond gear
oh oh well Rick looks like you're being
out class eh Oh got a one-up me it's not
hard now class we're not even in the
game
MOG guys added is that way T left the
game look I keep getting kicked by
mysterious forces haha Zama mysterious
force
in the sky thank you thank you thank you
mysterious well this building is crazy
okay so we're well I got signs in my
inventory just now what where where are
you guys actually on the theater
favorite ah how do I keep finding Rick
South 12th wheat and West MA or gate Hey
look you have a street named after you
okay so um
god damn zombies we need to find Laurie
and Bart Herschel's
and then survive some more all right I'm
in I'm inside a building
I went flying down this way to probably
nothing why didn't you blow up and die
Rick well that explosion would have like
that wouldn't you Shane
oh the car guys I'm at despawn but what
oh there's a little part our guide I'm
at a spot where where is spawn yeah
where we begun ha ha ha oh I have no
idea where you started you damn house
god damn it where we put good I'm just
good I want to I feel like making fun of
the British people right now no no no no
I don't oh there goes all of our UK
viewers off limpets I feel I'm gonna
Swedish people can I go you left me in a
trap here che yeah well I'm not Swedish
okay oh yes I am from Sweden land huh we
use the crew nor hail che we got a
problem in the middle of the road
Oh God Spezza joins Omo we see it
I found Hershel son Hershel
oh and watch you guys do that oh it's so
big
which is what Laurie said to me hey guys
Laurie say Wyatt Lord is there a reason
that his face are on his on his feet all
by myself oh we got an even bigger
problem over there about the hollows if
I had to guess I say it's about exactly
the same size no it's even bigger if
there's more I do in a different light
you know you know if you trim it up a
bit it looks a bit bigger you know
trimmed all that stuff at the base away
yeah yeah yes definitely looked a bit
bigger yeah huh-huh
whoa well you know oh come on
yes such a dick you know you did good
actually that's good oh I just wanted to
make another dimension with lots of real
ha ha ha yeah you died and went to
rollercoaster heaven huh that's so weird
oh look at her shell sifting through my
loot there are zombies on the raked eyes
there are giant zombies in every
direction what are we gonna do about
that all I have to fight without a phone
I have I have a sword if you want it
wait oh hey Scott you look good dude
there Rick I like how the giant zombies
appear to be very passive that's that's
helpful
they look passive they're just all
staining around like oh there you guys
Hershel for sharing so funny
that one looks pissed off I'll give it
that but alright so which one are we
going to attack if anything are we gonna
try to are we is there like objective
trying to escape the city is hard that
was kind of my objective I'd really like
to find a like I don't know a house
where we can like collect supplies and
then not have to just wander around
constantly house that would be if I had
to suggest a plan we should found the
eyes I'm just like fenced in our guys I
would recommend making a boat and
sailing
uh-uh
there is a yesh in here I guess pirate
Hershel gets to be the captain huh you
mean the floating gelatin horse nice Oh
Shane get my side misty the weird horses
in the sky isn't there some sort of boat
wink wink wink wink
um boat we talkin to kind of uh just I'm
praying you know are you praying to God
that the I pray funny image that we
mentioned praying Oh Walking Dead
minecraft God with which everyone is
familiar obviously to wonder if you even
exist anymore haha you know I I
understand that this is supposed to be a
town that was like devastated by the
zombie apocalypse why is there glass
everywhere
well wherever [ __ ] is all blown up
there's just glass all over the place
doesn't make any sense
have you ever been to a zombie
apocalypse I get what you're saying yeah
if something exploded there should be no
laughs everything was destroyed but the
glass the magic Pro glass explosion oh
oh oh I see someone hello hi oh is this
our fenced in area that we're gonna this
is it but this is our house
okay well I'll put a stone slab because
that's all I have yeah I'm not blocking
on our quarters we'll wait I see you
guys that is the worst possible house oh
shut up I've got you clay oh my blocks
let's see defendant defended ah
and then God defended oh oh you better
get it I just figured something out mark
what these light posts are actually made
of fence oh I'm a genius I wish I could
take some of this glass oh you guys are
down there are you pirate Hershel guys
I'm a peer her I was like that for bad
country singer Hershel here
to live for Oh God you think Hershel but
you're stronger oh god no oh God huh
that just got weird Oh sorrow thanks for
ruining it way Josh yeah sorry it's
awesome I try to do Smeagol it sounds
like a really bad Arnold Schwarzenegger
let's hear it Oh where's where I'm sorry
hey where'd Hershel go I'm [ __ ] yeah oh
oh where Shane I'm gonna kill myself
sounds so oh that wait no that's wait
where are you above you see you God
yourselves virtual job I'm gonna do jump
we don't care jump dink you did the no
no cares about it jump jump jump
oh what a wuss geez alright build up for
nothing okay we're buying our fenced in
area is complete how do I get in here
make us one opening guys this was the
spawn huh you can't get in was that is
that why this is a bad idea
so you're saying why is it why is there
redstone line leading what why is it
Red's done what's happening cuz redstone
line just leading out of nowhere over
there
it's the been will be TNT 200 but brick
up hey you dick I mean good job either
we get in I don't know there's a hole
I'm gonna put a door uh do you guys know
I see a little wooden fence to make a
house I try to actually give us a toast
I don't mean to you know break the
fourth wall but you do understand that
offense is like just as effective as
wall in this video game right blame you
woody [ __ ] it's like you don't even want
to protect were real mine hole blown I
know mine hole they're mine hole is
blown well that sounds kinda dirty yeah
oh hey stairs huh we might as well have
a classy house are we actually trying to
because we're we you know we do have an
internal quest to build a house that
never ever ever if we if we in this
situation like ten times
finally successfully build a house I'm
gonna like lose my [ __ ] guys
alright hola me but I'm in a desert
right now why I've been following the
redstone line it doesn't end why did you
go you pirate version I'll tell you
where the treasure is
yeah oh my god as she led me to loads of
diamonds what what yeah I know but I
don't have a pickaxe uh-huh wait hang on
does anyone have pig have a pickaxe
surprisingly I low mysteriously have a
pickaxe for no reason thank you
minecraft [ __ ] dead now I'm with
earth for no reason following the try
can't sprint though I'm all out of food
my car I've been healed ha
I call to the heavens all right we're
all set up for the apocalypse yeah but
we're not living there anymore oh no we
are living here we're moving we're
following the red zone
Wade and I are living here then Wade is
going the same way I am
oh you suck waves y'all are in there Bob
I planned on coming back I can just keep
working on the house and you guys can
come back yeah I will never follow the
same trail back that we're following in
this direction it's it's tough do you
have to like jump off a couple cliffs
and stuff I bet we probably do things
are all pirate Hershel let me do a
creeper trap I think oh I see what
you're talking about
oh oh oh oh my see it Oh my own it for
month you can't dig it I can hire my own
- you have to it oh no you can't dig it
I can dig it mine gah my mine half off
I'll treat y'all anything about killing
me to steal my diamond Oh / hey everyone
kill mark and steal a stylus Oh No hey
there they are
there's okay you just become an opera
there's a kid no I fell
you know II are you trying to kill me
we're not try we're just trying to save
here I mean here take the damn diamond
take the diamond jeez oh [ __ ] there's
like some Roman viaduct [ __ ] going on
here what is this there's a lot to this
Clara Hershel he knows we have diamond
he can't be allowed to leave oh I don't
think there was any way that wasn't
gonna happen just just to be clear there
you are Rob oh hi this is our cave home
now awesome how do I come suck it's the
apocalypse deal with it oh okay all
right so we have one and a half minutes
left episode what have we done again oh
yeah we should think go eat for one of
these buildings and call it our home and
count that uh-oh I see one over here do
it that's not could we leave like a
minute left do it quick Oh Marc can't
run I'm starving yeah I have 25 rotten
flesh if you wanna die ah I broke in da
oh I just seriously healed by the gods
above watch hey wait why are you getting
a tree no treat guys there's a hole in
our house so cute minecraft walking I'll
fill it in with these diamond boils I
have one fence ah fat [ __ ] miRNA I fill
in stuff there's a hole in this window
was huh wha huh where there's a door on
the door I found a door to but I don't
know
I put diamond I don't steal my diamond
that's Oh
company hey what's the explosion what
explosive I see no explosions wait duh
there was definitely explosions I don't
know but y'all crazy
yeah crazy yeah crazy what just happened
don't know how I work elf switch Wilson
we're um we're all out of time I think
unless some mysterious whose super duper
explosions gonna happen that I should
keep on camera but I don't see anything
ah uh uh uh-oh
Gangnam style oh yeah I was right there
with you Bob hahaha I saw that happening
okay so that was a piddly little silly
explosion off in the day some dumb [ __ ]
I don't cares about that knocking [ __ ] I
guess we should just end the episode so
alright thank you everybody so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done
check out yami master channel which is
feature high that's him bouncing around
is in the description thinking and I
have a channel two really cares about
waiting reprobate okay ah wait a panel I
also like to wait channel he's um what
was it doosh doosh what's your user name
who shot douche McGee no wait that's my
other username it's my awesome lord
minion something will be the description
or else markiplier won't make another
video uh all right so anyway so thank
you all so much for watching and as
always we'll see you in the next video
alright bye bye bye